إنه أمر فاحش تمامًا ما
نشاهده أه من الصعب أن نشاهد رؤية
الموت والدمار أه المذبحة
التي تلحقها إسرائيل
بجميع سكان غزة هذه
جرائم حرب هذه جرائم ضد
الإنسانية هذه إبادة جماعية هذا
تطهير عرقي ذلك  أمر مروع أه وعار على
الولايات المتحدة وبريطانيا والحكومات الأخرى
التي تدعم إسرائيل
وتبرير هذه التصرفات التي نحتاج إليها بشكل
عاجل ونحن نبني حركة
أه لتطغى على حكوماتنا على هذا
التواطؤ المخزي مع الجرائم التي
ترتكبها إسرائيل  ونحتاج من
الناس أن ينتفضوا كما هم في جميع أنحاء
العالم في الولايات المتحدة في بريطانيا في
أيرلندا أه للمطالبة بطرد
السفراء الإسرائيليين للمطالبة بعقوبات
على الدولة التي يمكن أن ترتكب هذه
الفظائع للمطالبة بالقبض على
نتنياهو وعصابته  المجرمين أه
وأه أن نفعل كل ما في وسعنا
لإعاقة قدرة إسرائيل جسديًا على
الاستمرار في جرائم الحرب هذه ضد
أهل غزة. النقطة المتعلقة بإسرائيل هي
أنها دولة منذ عام 1948 تم بناؤها
على التطهير العرقي على الإرهاب ضد
الشعب الفلسطيني  على الاحتلال غير الشرعي
للأرض الفلسطينية على أه سرقة
مستمرة للأراضي الفلسطينية
تطهير الشعب الفلسطيني من
منازلهم وقراهم والآن هذه
الإبادة الجماعية هذا هو منطق
الدولة الاستعمارية الاستيطانية المتفرقة
ولا مكان لها في العالم المتحضر